you can't help but want to be a part of
something that's so good sandy how long
have you been working with blockbuster
yourself
16 wonderful years why haven't you
jumped shipped to my netflix or
to someone why are you so loyal to
blockbuster uh you know what it's the
people
and the community i worked for a
corporation before this you know i was a
number who owns the entire brand who
owns the entire blockbuster brand the
brand is actually owned by dish network
what is dishes plan with blockbuster i
mean they bought him out of bankruptcy
i remember when somebody was talking
about this vending machine that kicks
out dvds
oh nobody's ever going to want to do
that and then next time we knew redbox
was everywhere
today everybody kind of uh is hoping
there's a resurrection with the
blockbuster
it's easy for me to sit back down go oh
they should have done this they should
have done that they really thought that
what they had was good and it wasn't
going to need to go
so i'm like okay what can we do that
netflix can't do well we can give that
personal touch to people
it becomes problematic when you're doing
everything yourself and they're not
coming out with anything for that ten
percent your pain
the nostalgia is wonderful the only
thing that's gonna keep the doors open
is our local community and we need to
remember that if i lose that attention
to my local customers we're not going to
be here
[Music]
so i want you to think about a company
called blockbuster multi-billion dollar
company from 1985
they start their first store in dallas
texas and in 2004
2005 9 000 stores 80 000 something
employees they're crushing it
and then all of a sudden blockbuster
breaks my heart goes out of business
because every friday night
i used to go run movies at blockbuster
and today's guest is a legendary guest
it's sandy harding who is the last
surviving blockbuster store
manager in the world so the song i'm a
survivor
was written and made and produced just
for her
sandy thank you for being a guest on
valuetainment oh thank you that was
quite an introduction thank you very
much
and by the way just so everybody knows
are you at the store right now
i am at the store i'm in my office which
is cluttered with
old stuff behind me you can see crates
of vhs and games and
all kinds of old signage it's just
crowded full of stuff now you know
everybody's got their own blockbuster
story you know for me when i think about
blockbuster i think about
a certain girlfriend you were dating at
the time i think about you know my dad
and i would go get movies and we'd watch
them
i think about the waiting outside the
glass and waiting for people to come and
return and you wanted to jump in and
i don't know if you know obviously
you've been around for a while so you
know that you would sit and say are you
returning this movie are you
i'll take it i'll take it hey john i got
it yeah no problem i mean all this stuff
that you experience
and uh but uh yeah the memories go all
the way back but for people that don't
know your story
sandy how long have you been working
with blockbuster yourself
so i celebrated my 16 years uh last
month
so i started actually in 2004 um i
opened up a location for kid and debbie
and was a store manager
um so yeah 16 wonderful years and
about six months it was a different
location than this one
six months after uh we opened that store
i transferred to the store
as the at the time i was the co-general
manager there was two of us
and we had five stores um and we divided
up the
the responsibilities so i did the
payroll personnel
kind of stuff and she melissa did all
the movie
orders and the candy orders you know the
other stuff behind the scenes um
and that lasted for a couple of years
together and then
she left and then i took over everything
um and so
um yeah it's been a whirlwind adventure
ever since i started
why why are you still around though i
mean you went from opal why haven't you
jumped shipped to my netflix or to
someone why are you so loyal to
blockbuster
uh you know what it's the people and the
community um 100
you know i worked for a corporation
before this um
and uh you know i was a number and
i did you know the i was a training
manager and i went around and i traveled
and i did stuff and i
i love the company i love the people i
worked with never thought in a million
years i'd ever worked for a mom and pop
for a small
business which i know the last thing
people think of when they hear
blockbuster as mom and pop
um you know got the famous how
blockbuster close all the mom and pop
shops
um and that irony has not been lost on
us as well that we
survived all of that but you know i i
needed a part-time job
out of the house away from my three
young sons i was going crazy and bonkers
looking for that um when i talked to
melissa
um and said hey can i have a can i get a
part-time job i'd known her for years
she and i were good friends um
and she said well actually we're opening
up a location we need a store manager
and i'm like oh man i really only want
to work about 20 hours a week
um but anyway that's how my story began
i came in
opened up that location and just have
been going since then and ken and debbie
are phenomenal people they take really
good care of us they really have
embraced kind of my customer service and
employee philosophy
has really been just right in sync with
theirs and it's been so nice to work for
somebody who
can appreciate people as much as i do
and gives me the freedom to really
you know treat this like my home and
that's exactly what it has been for the
last 16 years
now who did you say owns the company now
um ken and debbie tisher um
they have owned it this is actually our
20th years as a blockbuster
and our 30th year as a company so 2020
was supposed to be big celebrations for
us but as everybody in the world knows
you know all celebrations were kind of
put on pause yeah
um but yeah i know um they've been in
business for a long time
with the video stores now do they own
the who owns the entire brand who owns
the entire blockbuster brand
yeah the brand is actually owned by dish
network so they're the ones that
acquired blockbuster and bankruptcy
and you know at the time when they did
that we were a franchise
and in lieu of our franchise agreement
we signed licensing agreements with them
and we've just been signing that every
year um since
oh geez 2014 i think is when they
finally close the last store or 2015 i'm
terrible with dates
i should know these like the back of my
hand but you know it was kind of a
uh kind of messy situation for us
because when they were closing down
corporate stores you know
obviously we're franchises so we really
didn't know that was coming
um i can remember when they announced
that they were closing stores
we were actually we had actually closed
one of our locations
um because it now is a parking lot for a
ross dress for less uh
another store that moved into the mall
and our lease was up and
so we were out and they were in um and
so i know that we were
actually um moving the sign from that
location to another location
and that um sorry
i don't know i've been doing an
interview uh but anyway so we were
moving the sign from that location to a
different one and we didn't have our
sign in our building
and so we had people who did not know we
were still open and they were panicking
thinking that we closed because
blockbuster had just announced it and so
we were trying to convince people it was
terrible timing for us
for that particular location um and
that's you know we got the word the same
time everybody else did and so
it was kind of a lot of chaos during um
that time and it was really hard for
franchise owners you know we were
able to stay open but we had to combat
that national media
that kept saying that we were all
closing and trying to explain over and
over again that
no we are a franchise we're locally
owned we're right here in town we're not
closing we're not going anywhere
and it was kind of a struggle for a
while no what have you witnessed happen
from o4 till today because
i'm assuming when you're when you're
part of a brand like that
today everybody kind of uh is hoping
there's a resurrection with the
blockbuster
but blockbuster blockbuster's gone
through the phase of man we hope they
get you know
netflix comes and does something else
and oh my gosh i don't want them to go
out of business wait a minute they're
out of business oh my goodness they're
not there anymore
what have you seen happen with from o4
because the numbers i looked at the
revenue best revenue year
i believe for blockbuster was 05. uh
expansion wise was 04 but revenues 05.
so you you've been at the peak when it
was when you guys were crushing it
what have you seen happen from o4 till
today you know a lot of things because
you're right i started in the peak of it
i mean even for our locations you know
these stores have always done really
well which is why we're still here
um but even for us i mean i saw you know
an 0 405
going to you know franchise conventions
in dallas texas where
you know it's all started um until right
now with being the last store
it has just been just a crazy roller
coaster and
i know watching you know i came from i
was an outsider
so i had only been with a company um
for a year i think i don't even know if
i would have been here an entire year
before i went to my first
franchise convention and just watching
the old school
you know um
[Music]
it was just amazing to me because i was
listening to a bunch of guys talking
about the business and
i remember when somebody was talking
about this vending machine that kicks
out dvds
and i remember them talking about that
during the convention and thinking well
that's kind of interesting like oh
nobody's ever going to want to do that
and then next time we knew redbox was
everywhere um i remember them talking
about the
you know mail service and how they were
going to be you know shipping movies
home
to customers just kind of like netflix
was doing and and they were
starting to kind of see that netflix was
going to be a player in all of this
um but they really didn't appreciate
that they
were kind of behind the eight ball i
guess you want to say because they
really didn't jump into it when they
should have
and that's you know i don't want to play
the you know the armchair quarterback
or whatever and try to second guess
because i i certainly wasn't a part of
all those decisions and
it's easy for me to sit back now and go
oh they should have done this they
should have done that
but you know i think in a lot of ways
they really thought that what they had
was good and it wasn't going to need to
go anywhere
and they really under appreciated the
fact that people
love new they love i mean we're
americans
i mean you know we we like the newest
toy
the more expensive iphone i mean soon as
the new iphone drops we're out there
trying to buy it i mean
that's what that's what society is like
and and they really under
appreciated that and didn't realize that
they have to change they have to adapt
in order to stay um go ahead no i'm
sorry go ahead
no and i was going to say the irony of
that though is that i say those things
but yet we we haven't increased our
prices since i started
we haven't really changed other than
selling merchandise now
you know we've adapted to our customers
needs
which i think was the piece that was
missing for blockbuster they just kept
doing their same thing
um you know and they had the late fees
so when i started
in august of 04 we still had late views
when i opened up our location in
december of 04
that was the end of late fees program
which was a nightmare
and it was it was horrible and i i
understood what they wanted to do you
know which was
tell people hey you know we're not gonna
have late fees anymore come in rent
movies
but unfortunately the reality of it was
is you took all these great customers
that we had and you made them all angry
because now when they come in on friday
and saturday there's no movies on the
shelf because all your bad customers
took them out and kept them so you know
we used to have the guarantee in stock
that went away with the end of late fees
program so now customers are coming and
going well can i get a guarantee in
stock and we're like
no sorry we can't guarantee it now
because we don't have late fees
and we don't have a return time i mean
we have returned times but we can't
you know guarantee those movies are
going back on the show anyway it became
it became a mess and i think that you
know they really wanted to do something
but
i i mean i know that uh the documentary
for example
um that we have about the store that's
coming out in about blockbuster
it has to be the last one talks a little
bit about that and about
um you know they talked to somebody who
was like you know we went from
you know having you know the a large
revenue to literally cutting that
revenue down by
like three quarters or something crazy
the dollar amount that they talk about
that we lost
or that blockbuster corporate loss
during that time frame was what
astronomical and i understand they were
trying to do something positive for
customers
but as a company you you still have to
be in business
so i mean you probably should have taken
a little bit harder look at that
they also probably should have listened
to red hastings when he was in there
talking about us buying blockbuster
or by netflix too so 50 million yeah by
the way you're very intuitive
what you just said right there because
our audience is a lot of our audience
are entrepreneurs you just said
you know by getting rid of late fees
that means if me if i had to bring it
back to you in three days or seven days
now i can take five weeks and it's
sitting there but that means you're not
able to re-rent that to somebody else so
if you only have 40 of those movies
and those 40 moves are out there and
it's four dollars a pop that's 160
that's sitting there that i can't make
money on it so instead of trying to win
over my existing customers i try to
please my
unhappy customers and i even ended up
losing
my loyal ones that's a brilliant uh
lesson for any business person to take
away
well and we um as a as our franchise
because we're a franchise so we weren't
obligated
to go to the end of late peace program
however with a national campaign how
could you not
yeah that commercial it was a big
commercial that they did yeah
it was it would be incredibly difficult
for us not to be a part of that
so and of course again i wasn't a part
of that decision because i just
you know i'd only been with the company
less than six months so that was
something that kid and debbie
had to really think about but i
understand that you know there wasn't
anything else we could do um by o5
we had seen the writing on the wall and
watched how this was
a total mess in nightmare we switched we
went back
and when we went back we went back to a
per diem thing so
when a customer you know we have our our
late fees
um that are different so back in the
past you know you didn't return that
movie after three days it automatically
charged you for a full rental period
again
and that was a lot of things that were
upset about because next thing they know
they had a movie that was
you know ten days late and they owed
thirty dollars in in late
like that's just crazy so we didn't do
that when we did it we were like okay we
are going to charge
a dollar a day for every day that
they're late we're going to charge 50
cents a day for the older ones for every
daily so we tried to go to something
that was more reasonable
that our customers would still have to
be responsible to get the movies back
but yet it wasn't going to break the
bank and they weren't going to you know
go into debt to blockbuster or to us and
of course you know it's all about
customer service and i know i would have
employees that would come to work for us
that
worked for corporate stores and they
were much stricter about
taking fees off for customers much
stricter about you know working with
people
whereas a franchise we were like oh no
first time you've had late fees
absolutely let's take it off let's
educate you let's
let's make you aware of how this system
works so that the next time you come in
oh you forgot again
we'll cut them in half for you and then
the next time we're like okay we've
we've done all these things now now you
know so
now you got to start being responsible
get your movies back so i mean
from a customer service standpoint
you've got to get your customers
to that point where they get it they
understand it they're responsible for it
and everybody's happy um i mean you're
still gonna have people take advantage
of the system but
no question about it you've gotta you
gotta work with people
in a in a more positive way that
benefits the business
okay what do they say you know you
you take off one one customer and they
tell ten you make one
happy they tell two yeah i mean it's
like you've got a you got to kind of win
that back
and keep people from leaving your door
unhappy so that is so true
and and it's a be back business meaning
you know when i say be back you're
winning me over like you know
you have some customers today that just
don't like netflix so maybe it is the
nostalgic you know feeling of let me go
over here and i kind of want to go
through the experience let's go walk the
aisles
let's see what's over here there was
something unique about it but
you know going back to what you said
when you went to the franchisee
conventions back in the days i think the
blockbuster franchise fee was somewhere
between 150 000
to 700 000 it was a big number you
weren't paying
a small number you could end up paying
700 000 to get the whole thing going
when you went to the conventions at the
time and netflix is coming out and all
these other guys were coming out
did you hear the leaders at the top you
know
downplay that there's no way that's
going to work did you hear them bring up
netflix and other competitors regularly
or was there more
people are never going to get away from
running from a movie you know renting
from a store like ours we're always
going to be in business
what did you hear from the messenger at
the top now obviously i'm saying this
i know you are now working for
blockbuster's
franchisee with with ken and debbie and
dish owns you so it's not like you're
calling out your existing ceos
yeah i'm just trying to find out like
what it was like when you went to the
conventions
so there was you know when i first
started going to conventions i i was
like i said
new i mean i had only been with the
company for less than a year so
a lot of this stuff was pretty new to me
and i was really just dumbfounded by
the the kind of schmoozing
i guess you want to call it it was more
that the corporate
world would come in and oh yeah we're
franchise owners let's go in there and
and kind of you know they weren't really
giving us a lot of information or at
least wise
for me the average franchisee now i
don't know
you know we had the abf which was our
franchise business consultants they were
you know
big group and i know kim was involved in
that at one point um
and i know that they probably had better
communication with the corporate
blockbuster higher-ups than we did as
just the franchisees sitting at the
table in the convention room but
um from what i saw was just a lot more
of them trying
to you know pass on the back hey you
guys are all doing a good job
you know kind of give us a lot of uh lip
service
i mean i guess there's no other you know
positive way to say it i mean that's
basically what it felt like
and it didn't necessarily feel like they
were taking all of those things
seriously to us
it's like you bring up a conversation
it's like oh well we're doing this this
this and of course everything is all
positive
there wasn't you know you've been in in
conference meetings before
many with different businesses and you
know how it goes i don't want to hear
what positive things i want to see
action
i want to see results and it's like you
can give me all the lip service you want
you can tell me how wonderful it's going
to be
but if i don't actually see results and
i'm not getting any answers
then you're just you're just giving me
words coming out of your mouth to make
me happy because i'm here for three days
and then i'm going back home
and it's like you know i want to see a
real plan
of what we're going to do as a result of
this you know our numbers were starting
to go down and
and really here at our locations we were
um
we had the benefit of not having any
corporate stores around us
and we had a hollywood video here in
town we had some mom-and-pops but
you know we um we had four stores here
in bend so we definitely had
you know the bigger uh market i guess
you want to say or we have that
you know the bigger piece of the pie um
here in town and so we probably didn't
feel the effects that some of the bigger
towns felt you know um in texas and
different places where they had lots of
corporate owned blockbusters and lots of
franchise owners so i mean we had
you know good producing stores and and
we made good money here
at the time but we still were feeling
the effects of having redbox across the
street we were still feeling the effects
of netflix
we were still hearing customers coming
in going oh you work at blockbuster
blockbuster's old news
you know i i remember now when i walk
into costco people see me and recognize
me for blockbuster they're like super
excited and oh my god you work at the
coolest place ever
i remember when i go on the block or
into costco in different places and not
want to tell people
because i didn't want to hear about how
negative it was and how
you know not a business so i mean
it just was very frustrating for me
being a newcomer and seeing that hey
you know i'm not i'm not listening to
the same old same old that you're
telling me every time i don't see
results and i don't understand
why you people aren't taking this more
seriously and and you know the franchise
owners i could see
the frustration on their faces the
actual owners
and i was there and i was there more to
you know find out what the new
you know pop which is what they called
it which was the new what the stores are
going to look like you know
what are we going to do for christmas
and what kind of movies are coming out i
mean i was more
focused on that but i also had worked in
business long enough to watch the other
things and the franchise owners getting
really frustrated because
they weren't getting the kind of the
answers that they were looking for they
weren't getting the support and the help
and
um you know and they were paying an
enormous amount of fees i mean the
the amount of money that we were paying
to blockbuster every month was it was a
good chunk of money
to not be getting you know the the
answers so what was the number
was it 10 or was it more like six
percent you know um i
i think it was closer to 10 but i don't
know because at the time remember
it's a big number yeah i was doing the
payroll and personnel stuff and i wasn't
doing the financial stuff so
that'd be more of a question for ken but
i know it was not it was not cheap
i mean we were definitely paying them a
good chunk and um
and definitely didn't feel like we're
getting our bang for a buck kind of a
thing
that's the thing that's the thing with
franchisee people don't mind paying the
money if the company at the top is doing
their part
it becomes problematic when you're doing
everything yourself and they're not
coming out with anything for that ten
percent you're paying
it can be very frustrating what what's
kept you around
is it are you more around because ken
and debbie have become more family
to you are you more around because of
the you know
you just love what the company and the
story is all about or is it just your
personality
you're loyal you stick around and you
just kind of make it work until
you know they decide to shut down which
one of the reasons is why you're still
around 16
of all three i think that i am a very
loyal person
and ken will tell you that i'm loyal to
my own detriment
that i tend to to you know work the 60
hour a week you know even though i'm
salary
um but at the same time i mean you can't
help but want to be a part of something
that's so good
um you know we're very community focused
and i'm a part of something that's
not just good for for me but it's good
for all of us
and you know we just had the airbnb
event last weekend which was
a lot of fun uh but it was very
community driven and it was all about
giving back to people here you know
during copen we didn't want to encourage
anyone to travel
um and so we offered it for four dollars
a night which everybody's like are you
crazy you know you could make like you
know 100 times that amount everyone
wanted to do it but it wasn't about that
it was about the fact that
you know when the tourism goes away when
the media stops calling me for
interviews
the only thing that's going to keep the
doors open is our local community and we
need to remember that so
we still are very much a part of that
and you know that four dollars a night
was meant for
a customer could come in and rent a
movie and take it home or they could
come in and rent the whole store and
watch whatever they wanted to for one
night
and so it was meant to be kind of a fun
thing for just locals to say hey thanks
for all the years
that's awesome we you know we've tried
to do as many things as we can over the
years and
i always give out as many shout outs to
the other small businesses in town
because
you know all of our merchandise that we
sell online for example all of it
is acquired through a bench store a bed
company
so even if uh you know they're only
printing it they're still buying it from
somewhere else they're printing it here
locally
and they're getting paid by me so um you
know i've had lots of people that have
told me hey why are you doing that why
are you not just buying it online and
getting it for
you know you know at least 30 cheaper
than what you're paying now and i'm like
yeah but that doesn't bring the money
back to bend and the whole reason why
we're still here
is the bad community and so i think that
people really appreciate that
that we've done that yeah and the fact
that i can work for ken and debbie who
uh support me on that
and are like no you're you're spot on
it's all about community it's all about
taking care of each other
that we're able to do those things now
that doesn't mean we haven't struggled
that doesn't mean that you know saving
that 30 on those hoodies wouldn't help
my bottom line it absolutely would but
again
when the tourists stop buying those
hoodies this ben's what's going to
support me and if i turn my back on bend
and
and just go straight push forward to the
tourism aspect and
become an airbnb every week and all
those things ben is going to be like
whatever you're just another corporate
sellout and i don't want to be that i
want to keep being the small
locally owned store we've always been
and the nostalgia is wonderful
i mean we have people that travel here
all the time to see us and um
you know short of working for disneyland
i don't think that i can work anywhere
else that
every customer that walks the door is
happy to see me every day
um it's a very positive happy place to
work and
right now in this world i i don't know
that i'd want to leave that
i mean this is it's just a very
wonderful place to be
you know you said talk about disneyland
and i think it was in um
i don't know what year was oh wait or
sonata away literally prior to that
when blockbuster got approval to build
an amusement park in miami a massive
little park that they were going to
build i mean the stories
that they have uh uh is uh is insane of
what they were doing at one point
but are you guys profitable right now is
enough business coming in where you're
staying
okay that's great what you know going
back i run a business i have
16 17 000 insurance agents nationwide uh
i'm the ceo and the founder of the
company i do this
on the side it's not what i do full time
what were some innovative campaigns
where
for you if you were to say you know like
mcdonald's came out with an innovate
campaign called
share a coke and they would put a name
on there bob mary jack oh my gosh let me
i'm not even a coke person jack let me
take you to my friend bob let me take
you to work it'd be cool to share with
them
it's a great campaign that they did
right you see a lot of different
companies
that do great campaigns what are some
things you think they could have done at
that time with the late fee
that would have been a great campaign or
even any other campaigns they could have
done that maybe would have brought back
the customers have you i'm sure
there's been a lot of discussions a lot
of topics talks about that what are some
things they could have done
well i think they could have done more
charitable things and and i don't know
now i say that um but i don't know
all the things that they were doing
behind the scenes kid but all you ever
really saw was oh yeah they're doing the
oh they had like an awards like a
blockbuster awards thing
kind of like the oscars kind of thing i
mean not to that level but i know they
had an awards thing
i think you're right about the amusement
park i mean you always saw these big
huge things they were doing
um for them and maybe they should have
done more for others
and i think that you know for us for
example like the airbnb thing you know
we
we really supported our local humane
society which is a huge thing for us and
in central oregon we're all about pets
and animals and and all of those things
and
um you know we try to support as many
things but with late fees
i would love to have seen them you know
if you're going to keep the late fees
that you are maybe
say for every you know dollar we get for
late fees we're giving a dollar to a
local charity
i mean i think that a lot of times you
got to focus on your communities that
you're
in and i mean even um
you know i've worked for lots of
different businesses too and and done
different things over the years
and i find that if you focus more on the
on the local aspect and the person
that's in your business
at that time and you're focused on that
person and not so much
about what's happening outside it's
going to bring back tenfold
and i mean i i talk about the first week
we became the last one in america
i remember i had a customer you know we
were super busy we were not expecting
that we we had no
you know i was in the parking lot across
the street my son had been in a fender
bender and i was talking to a police
officer when usa today called me
and i had no idea that this was coming
and i remember being in our store and we
were super busy
and we were helping customers and i
can't remember if it was the new york
times or the washington post but one of
them called
and they were on the phone and they're
like oh my god it's the new york times
and i was like
okay well i've got a customer in front
of me and the customer's like but it's
the new york times i'm like but you're a
pain customer
and you're the reason i'm here i'm like
the new york times can wait let me
let me check you out and then and
everybody was shocked that i did that
i'm like no it's like you know
i think it's exciting and it's fun and
i'm so happy to be on all these programs
but the bottom line is that customer in
front of me is what's paying
my wage that's what's keeping my doors
open and if i lose that
and if i lose that attention to my local
customers
then we're not going to be here for
another you know
20 years i mean we have to stay focused
on that and so i think sometimes in the
corporate world
that gets forgotten and i think if they
had maybe paid more attention to those
things
you know allowed their employees like we
we do fun stuff you know we have an
employee pick section and we do
we have a barbecue that we do every year
and we were doing it in my
um my backyard but last year we actually
did it at the store because there were
so many ex-employees that were coming
and it was so fun and you know we do
more of those kind of things that are
more focused on it and
you know i'm known as the blockbuster
mom and unfortunately now i'm starting
to be known as the blockbuster grandma
which i'm like oh my gosh i'm not you're
sure i've got my own grandkids i'm not
sure if i'm ready for that yet but i i
really
think that that's important to be a part
of that and i i know i'm probably from
an hr manager standpoint probably their
biggest nightmare
because you know i love my employees i
love my customers this is my family
how i operate the business every day and
i think if more
businesses treated things like a small
business
they would be more successful if they
kept track of what's happening
right now in my store today what's
happening and not worried about what
might happen tomorrow
and focus on the here and now i mean
and that's they train us like that for
our our personal lives right
it's all about being mindful it's all
about you know you got to be mindful of
your situation be mindful of what's
happening now and not do the what ifs
and
i mean you have to do some of those as a
business owner you have to you know you
have to know your cash flow is good you
have to know that
you have to plan for those things but
when it comes to customers you have to
focus on here and now
every customer that leaves my business
unhappy
that doesn't fi if i can't find a movie
for them watch even if i don't have that
new release on the shelf
i need to be out there helping them find
something else so that they leave happy
yeah that's a great point and by the way
i think you're still
the blockbuster mom i think grandma you
i know your age because i research you
we're we're on this we're a couple years
apart so you're
if you're a grandma then i'm a grandpa
i'm not ready for your grandfather so
we're gonna stay
moms and dads for now yeah but you know
you make such a great point i you know
sometimes you when you you
when you interview people we have a lot
of guests and we've had you know mark
cuban oh my gosh you know he's worth
four billion dollars or chipos and worth
four billion he started
lululemon it's like oh i'd love to be a
billionaire but very rarely do you are
you able to learn
from a franchise 84 000
employees 9 000 stores 4 500 in america
this was a brand that was all over the
place
for it to go from there to a fall what
happened there's a lot of good things
you're talking about
here with us but the question for you
with the pattern of customers today
do you notice a pattern with customers
age
are they a little quirky are they chippy
what do you notice like what is common
about all the customs because it's dvds
it's not like
i mean they have to still have a dvd i
don't even i don't even know if i have a
dvd do you have a dvd player trials
i don't even know if i have a dvd player
on my house so if i come to you i almost
have to have a dvd player on my house
so what are some of the patterns of
customers you're having right now
well and absolutely we have a little bit
of everything and and there for a while
i mean
we definitely the niche was the older
customers okay
when we were struggling when the whole
company was going under
and everybody was struggling i i know we
definitely had a lot more older
customers and
and that makes sense because i can tell
you from having you know
20 something children that they're all
about the newest technology we kind of
talked about that a little bit ago
and uh you know we have netflix at home
and i think my son
wait did you say 20-something children
oh yes my children
yes my youngest will be 20 next month so
it's it's kind of scary but my children
are all in their 20s
my daughter will be 30 in december so
it's kind of scary
um so see now you're now you're
definitely aging me here
you did it yourself don't put it on me
but no you know having those them at
home i mean we do again
you know we have netflix at home and and
i know my son has hulu and
and you know we have different streaming
services and and i i think that you know
you have to keep you have to let know
that that's going to be the case
you know everybody's always like oh how
do you compete with those things and i
know i'm a little off the topic of what
you asked me but
you can't really compete with that i
mean that is going to be what it's going
to be
i mean but the thing is is that instead
of trying to
compete you just embrace the fact that
it's there and say okay well these
customers have netflix at home but what
do i have that netflix doesn't have
well i have a library here of over 25
000 movies on my shelves
and you know and it may not be 25
different titles but i have 25 000
movies on the show
which by the way i didn't know that till
covet and we did a full inventory i
thought we had closer to like 18 19.
but um you know we still have a very
large amount of movies
netflix you know they can i'm sure you
saw our billboard where we had the
algorithm billboard
so i'm like okay what can we do that
netflix can't do well we can give that
personal touch to people
we can you know they would have to go to
netflix hulu amazon
um gosh all the different streaming
services they'd have to have all of
those at home
to have the same library that i have
here so rather than focusing on what
you know what netflix has let's focus on
what they don't have they don't have
the variety that i have in the store so
that was one of the things that we kept
doing we have a
suggestion list for customers and if i
don't have the movie they
tell us what movie they would like from
you see i search it now i don't buy
every single movie because as
a as a company i can't i mean if i
if i research something it's 30 well
that doesn't make any sense for me to
bring that title into the store even one
customer rents it
i'm paying thirty dollars for you know
two bucks somebody rents it i'm not
gonna make my money back so
i need to make sure that i'm i'm
purchasing things that'll be beneficial
for the store long term
so there are some times when i have to
say no but customers understand that
and i explain it to them be like you
know unfortunately it's too much i can't
afford to buy that movie
and then a lot of times that customer
like well i'll buy it and i'll just
donate it to you so i can't tell you
oh no i do we have people donating
movies every day so they'll buy it and
they'll watch it and then they'll donate
it back because
that part of that is that honesty thing
that i have with my customers they know
that if i can do it i will do it
if i can't then i'm going to tell them i
can't and here's why
and i think that it's that relationship
that we've built with our customers
that has come back and part of it was
having that older generation
during that that struggling period where
they appreciated good service
they appreciated my willingness to go
out of my way to help them
and they knew that they could always
count on me for my honesty and i think
that the older generation really counted
on that and then
and we really kind of fostered
a really good working relationship with
those customers
um and then now with the nostalgia piece
we're seeing all those families come
back
and it's kind of come full circle people
you know they might still like i said
have netflix and hulu and everything
else at home
amazon and apple and disney plus and
everything else that's out there
but what they don't have is they don't
have that opportunity to get out of
their house
to come to blockbuster with their kids
something they did with their family
when they were younger
and have just an afternoon where they
can go pick a movie
and they can actually their kids can
touch it it's tangible they love
coming in and picking it up and carrying
it around something you don't get on
netflix
i mean we talked about that with our
algorithm you can go on there and
and you know i know on on netflix and i
know yesterday i was
looking at something and i didn't
realize on under my husband's name
instead of my name and
he watches every reality show possible
and i'm like why are these reality shows
on mine i don't watch those
i mean it's great that they have that
algorithm so i'll tell you what you want
but maybe tonight i do want to watch
that
now i've got to go past all the other
crap i got to remember what i'm
on that page i got to search it or i can
just come in here and walk over to the
documentaries and pick up a documentary
and that's something that we just had to
make sure that we focus on what we do
have
and not what we don't yeah that's very
that's
very powerful because that's what choice
do you have what can you do you can talk
about what you don't have and
it's going to drive you insane there's
no way you're going to compete with them
directly in that area
i remember family video i remember
hollywood video but i was a
even today i forgot is it video 2020 or
2020 video i don't know if you remember
2020 video it was a spot in la we'd go
rent and
you know that was my spot and obviously
they're no longer in business but it was
blockbuster was warehouse
totally forgot about warehouse it was
warehouse blockbuster
and it was uh video 2020. so what what
what is
dish net what is dishes plan with
blockbuster i mean they bought them out
of bankruptcy
do they tell you what they want to do do
they have any idea they just bought it
just to buy it
yeah and i think they probably at one
point had plans of some things they
wanted to do i don't think they intended
to just close all the stores i think
unfortunately by the time they got it
it was just in so much trouble there
really wasn't much they could do with it
um you know and i know that they have
you know a small amount of licensees
um that people that use the name and i
think that that's definitely interesting
that has grown since we became the last
one and
and i it's uh it's kind of a sad it's
kind of a
i don't know probably because i am so
loyal
and it frustrates when we when other
people try to take advantage of that
situation but i know even when we were
setting up our website
you know we had done um blockbuster bend
on everything
and we ended up having to do and i'm
going to get this backwards and my son
will laugh at me because he's the one
that designed the website with
another old manager that we had but we
went to to do it and we had set up our
facebook and we set up twitter and we
set up our instagram one way
and we went to do our our website and
someone else had already bought it and
opened it up
and had a page a web page that looked
exactly like us
representing it as if it was us and i'm
like what are these people doing and
like i get it
it's an opportunity for you to get your
15 minutes it's opportunity for you to
make money
and i know that and i know that's what
people are driven by that and
and i am have no problem with
entrepreneurs doing you know what they
need to do to have that american dream
but i'm like seriously so and i knew
that their intention was for us to buy
that from them well
we are not in a position to do that so
we just had to tweak it and make it
something else and just keep going
forward i mean i couldn't dwell on it it
wasn't something i was going to have to
to worry about it just
is what it is and we just move forward
but
you know i don't know that dish um has
big plans for the blockbuster name i
know there's certainly people who have
called me up and wanted to do
open up their own franchise or open up
their own store and i
i kind of laugh i'm like yeah you're
right right now we're pretty popular and
and people are coming and renting movies
but i don't think you realize what it
was going to take to get your library
of 20 000 movies um i don't think you
realize
you know what it takes to actually
operate a brick and mortar business
you it's not just go open up a store and
you're going to become instantly
successful and i think that part of the
reason we're still here
is we have the nostalgia piece we have
those loyal people that want to come in
and support us
i don't know if there was 20 stores left
that we would be doing as well as we're
doing right now
i don't know if someone popped up one
all of a sudden in la that it's gonna do
really well because you're right most
people don't have dvd players
and they come in and they see us and
they support us because they know that
we're
you know not going to be here forever
and they want us to last as long as we
can
and that's just the reality of it and i
think that people sometimes forget
i saw posting today about family home
video
um which is big in the midwest you
mentioned them earlier i think that
they're getting ready to
close some stores and part of that is
because they're struggling right now and
like every other small business across
america everybody's struggling with
cobin
and the reality of the situations that
people haven't and i think sometimes
people forget
that you know right now what we have is
unique and cool and
and great because we're we're on our own
remember the last one and so we have all
these awesome things that are happening
out there for us
but i don't know that that would be the
case if they started popping up
blockbusters everywhere
i think unless somebody was really smart
about how they did it
um i don't know that that would be super
successful and i mean we can look back
and be like oh man what the heck were
blockbuster thing in when they bought
what was it paramount or universal or
one of the big
you know they uh but was it viacom i
think that bought
part of that um and they you know
started uh funding that um
studio with money from blockbuster and
really got it up and going well
you know that was great but how could
they not know that that was going to
kill blockbuster i mean you can't
you can't take all the money out of one
business and push it off into one
another one without
hurting them both i mean any smart
business person knows that if you've got
one diet business and you're funding it
from the other successful business
eventually you're going to have two
dying businesses
if you're not careful so you have to
really be smart about it um
and make smarter decisions and i don't
know i i'm just
a manager here so i'm again you're more
than a manager i mean
you're more than a manager if this
doesn't work out for you could easily be
be a consultant for a lot of companies
but uh but uh
did you say blockbuster.com is owned by
somebody else not blockbuster
is that so no um our website
or your website i got it yeah the
blockbuster.com is definitely still dish
network
um they have that name um but when we
were trying to do our own website
and we were doing the blockbuster bend
that makes sense somebody had that
already
on your twitter account what was really
cool is uh on august 11 you know this
already yeah
blockbuster decides to send a tweet and
they said hey
just check it in and it got 954
000 likes 141 000 retweets
and a few hours later they said okay
we've seen enough checking out
[Laughter]
i think it was uh it was definitely
funny that dish did that
i think um that was right at the same
time we were talking about the airbnb
stuff kind of rolled it out the same day
and i thought that was great
um did you get bombarded when that
happened or did you like did you get a
bunch of calls customers people coming
in
did you notice the the traffic or no
yeah no we definitely did and we
definitely heard a lot of people from it
um every time that something like that
happens we get a lot of phone calls
you know when uh captain marvel had
you know her you know breaking into a
blockbuster i can't tell you how many
people are calling me going oh my god is
that your store and i'm like no that's
not our store
disney didn't call me i'm sorry i didn't
let anybody smash into my store
um but now anytime anything like that
happens we get a lot of phone calls
well listen i just wanted to uh share
this story because i think
there are so many things all of us can
learn from this
but it's also uh it takes a very special
person to be you
i don't think it's everybody's job to be
you and
in a way it's very obvious you can and
debbie have a very very great
good relationship together props to them
as owners to be able to keep someone
like you and be loyal
and uh for you to do your part and care
about the profits as much as
the customers where you become somebody
that the owners can just trust around
the place and operate the place
it's tough to find people like you out
there it's it's a you're
you're very very hard to find and you're
very very valuable
to a business owner and uh sandy i just
wanted to tell you i appreciate you for
taking the time for being a guest here
and i'll give you the final words
anything else you want to say to the
viewers here before we wrap
up take care of your small business take
care of your small businesses in your
community
because they all need lots of love and
support right now to keep them open
just don't forget local buy local
whenever you have a chance
sandy you're amazing thank you for your
time bye-bye
you know many times we sit there and we
talk to people who are billionaires on
how they made their billions how do they
become millionaires how did you become
successful
you only think about all the things they
did right and you don't get the blind
spots right and then you sit down with
somebody
like sandy who's a manager the only
blockbuster remaining and she's been
there since 04
and you learn so much more about what to
do to make sure your company never fails
mind boggling how this interview was
with sandy it was
amazing for somebody like me that's an
operator i run a company to see
what things she had to talk about that
they try to focus on all their
customers were not happy by doing so
they lost the customers that were happy
what do you do to keep your loyal
customers you're still going they still
want you to do this
and then all of a sudden you lose
everybody so it was uh it was intense it
was a
a very very good message for any
entrepreneur and business owner to
listen to
i got another video i want you to watch
if you got a lot of this sit down here
uh i sat down with patty mccord patty
mccord is the former
chief talent officer of netflix she was
with reed hastings
for 14 years and she talks about how
they operated the company how they
recruited people
how they hired people how they fired
people what their culture did to get
them to where they're at today of 150
200 billion dollar company
and to go from a company that was
irrelevant she even talks about a story
when they went into a room
and you know everyone said oh my gosh we
just crossed a million customers
and reads like awesome you guys can
celebrate but i'm off to five million
she tells all these stories if you now
watch that interview it's a powerful one
click over here to watch that interview
and if you've not subscribed to the
channel please do so thanks for watching
everybody take care bye